kann sich nur noch um momente handeln ja
bahn frei erzählt humba humba humba
humba humba runde warum warum warum
warum warum warum baum
hallo ich in freunde herzlich zur post
mahlzeit sieht man gar nicht dass gerade
daran allerdings getrunken hast hier
eine super diese diät aber du kommst dir
richtig bleibt bis zum grab ich esse mal
die erste garde mit auch gedacht wir
haben so viel drauf in berlin gaben an
dieser aufnahme session auf und es macht
echt richtig spaß also wir sind mit
leidenschaft dabei das ist echt cap
defines war zwar am anfang auch geil
aber das ist auch normal das ist viel
geiler also den skeptikern liegt und ich
möchte daran an diesen scheiß ich sage
es einfach mal auf gut deutsch an diesen
scheiß gelben kleiderwahl jeden komplett
können wir dann hier drauf platzieren
und da es als richie fans fehlen uns
noch dafür sein 23 mann ich schaue hier
ist auch schon wieder neues holz und
alle wir müssen echt langsamer schauen
also älter wir werden heute die mit der
bahn frei ich hole jetzt loren die
schienen ich mache den erfolg hast du so
direkt zu jacob machen diese war das und
ich sie ja hallo erst mal herzlich
willkommen zur capt minecraft zwei das
konnte ich noch nicht mal sagen
zusammengekommen und mir und ich habe
schon wieder schluckauf immer immer an
dir einen kommentar es ist echt langsam
peinlich
ich mache mir mal ganz großen schaufeln
ja mach das so ich mache nur holstein
stoffe weisen schaffen jetzt auch nicht
unbedingt so wartet das holz da hast du
noch sticks legal keine habe ich gehe
dann macht man eben wieder vier neue
zwei davon verbräuchen die schaufel mit
den rest mache ich eben die anderen zwei
mache ich mir fackeln raus ich habe
schon überlegt irgendwann geht es ja ein
netter und die dings haben wir schon die
glasflaschen und wir haben auch schon
kloster und staub zum verzaubern
ja also ein paar sachen aber ich nehme
eben die goldnuggets und macht daraus
schon mal goldbarren weil wir haben 21
stück daraus kann man schon mal zwei
normale gold machen oder braucht nicht
nur für das normale gold hier so zwei
gold weil irgendwann machen wir uns dem
lot apple und mit diesem also die
meinten das wäre dass ich tief mit der
archiv mensch so nach dem motto so das
müsste man so ein ende machen irgendwie
so karl ladung dauert auch sich das
gesamtjahr waltz genau weiß
wahrscheinlich lange dauert so ich packe
meinen die ganze suppe schalen die linke
kiste wir müssen dass ich dann eh mal
sortieren das wieder durchblicken so
moment hier noch welche reihen
so war wo bist du ich bin ganz ruhig ich
war gerade dabei sich anschlossen
bisschen ja ja gerne halten einen
schluckauf es einen kleineren kleineren
kreis setzte der malen könne
während die luft in kabul das geld mehr
gehabt ich weiß nicht ob es in ghom es
voll gewahrt an meiner wir haben
herausgefunden dass es diese statistiken
gibt unserer leider glaube ich obwohl
und da ist uns aufgefallen dass man da
sehen kann wie weit man schon gefahren
ist und du machst das jetzt mal bitte da
drauf ich hoffe dass das ganze so
funktioniert nicht dass man das ganze
ist also eher steht wahrte er steht ich
jetzt nicht nach aber ich weiß dass da
steht dass es jetzt nämlich funktioniert
war diesmal gleich wieder an so schön
ich habe schon wartet immer sagen ich
habe ja schon 200 meter hinter mir
du bist schneller als ich ich kann ich
mich schützen hallo du bist echt schnell
unterwegs
hey warte mal habe ich schon die 300
meter oh ja sogar noch die fackel der
mitte geflohen geflogene strecke für 108
meter geflogen
ja getauchte strecke zwei meter in lohr
gefahrenmoment 300 meter gibt geflogen
eventuell soll wir uns eventuell wegen
dingsbums wald werden wichtig denn ohne
gott ja ich hab ich geschossen
das geht ja mal ab du bist nicht
vorschnell jetzt wirds langsam wieder
langsam mal wieder ein bisschen zack
obwohl mir das hat nicht viel gebracht
und 400 meter mehr
krass alter was geht ab montag wieder
schaffen hat was gibt's denn sonst noch
so viel schief münster brot backen brot
auf weizen dafür müssen wir das
anpflanzen und dafür brauchen wir erde
ich frag mich echt wandern erde kommen
dann kommen immer wieder neue kisten
sommer schauen dann hier in den markt
kommen also ich muss ich an chips mit
der oberhafen dach da oben auf dem dach
teilweise ein bisschen berg guck mal
hier beim werk wo ich gerade im test
auch noch ein bisschen sollte alles noch
hier oben brauchen wir gar nicht als
vier wochen ich freue mich so wenn wir
jetzt steyn play oder blues train
playoff ich bin auch richtig gespannt
was dann kommt
ich frag mich aber schon habe mich schon
abgefunden
okay weil damit könnten uns ja blauen
farbstoff machen und den können wir dann
mit dem ton den wir haben
mein züge das also ich weiß ist das
gedicht doch dass du kannst ja gleich
mal minecraft wie die gucken weil das er
kann meine folge ist dann möchte ich
nicht unbedingt
na ja manchmal schon rum schaffen das
ist aber laut statistiken
es steht dort nicht moment wo china
setzt getauchte geflogene runde gefahren
also ich hab schon 700 meter okay okay
gut dort nicht mehr so lang dass wir so
eine scheiße wieder wachen möglich es
ist nimmt schon wieder so die alten form
angabe falscher dass wir uns ein kurpark
urban wir könnten aber rein theoretisch
auch runter mal wieder in die höhle weil
er war ja noch diese eine neue höhen
abschnitte monstern und da gehen wir
gleich hin
ja das machen wir vielleicht erst mal
dass wir das hier mit der lore schnell
fertig kriegen
auch gleich hier so schon fast 900 meter
so jetzt bitte noch mal schnell alter
wirklich schnell mir also ich habe jetzt
aber dass aktualisiert sich wir mal
nicht da kommt mir gibt keiner recht
barsch okay jetzt will ich meinen 95
shops noch mal an
950 meter gleich hab ich die kilometer
juli macht sich warm für die humba humba
tanz es kann sich nur noch um momente
handeln ja ja bahn frei zum bau warum
warum warum warum warum warum warum
warum
und es steht zehn zu acht mal die
partien mitnehmen
endlich geht's nämlich zum glück auch
mal in deiner folge mensch man man man
jetzt arbeiten erfolgt dann kann er
wieder nach unten gehen was gibt es
alles noch so naja wir können das noch
mal probieren mit dem fischfang in
diesem team wir haben jetzt wasser
irgendwie konnte anja macht und handelns
machen you know how los angeles oben
machen ja weil hier unglaublich sieht
das nicht so toll aus der dann wär was
auch geil ich mache eine angelockt
ja klar ich glaube es müssten in der
kiste liegen nämlich abzufackeln gemacht
da muss die neue stelle machen ok du
brauchst glaub ich drei stück oder nicht
mehr
ich glaube einfach nur 3 ich wohne ich
glaube auch hier am rand übrigens dieses
braune zeigt dass es wirklich nur zur
deko das braucht man nicht unbedingt
welches das fahrzeug
dieses ist diese braunen gewächse oben
auch das okay
so warte ich mache mal eben ganz kurz
hier
du kannst noch ein bisschen warten mit
einer denk ich muss ja eben das gar
nicht so lange gerade einfach mal
drauflos
soja angel du mal einfach als rutschten
gar nicht mal so schlecht aus überall
kommen wir diesen kleinen bläschen
quartier sollte vielleicht hier oben
erstmal sonne bist du hast gerade in
unserer kleinen ich mag ihre hat nämlich
oben sonntag in euch probiert war
fröhlich drauflos mal wieder macht das
bestimmt
natürlich hoffe ich kriege unendliche
quelle irgendwie hin
ok so ein bisschen komisches geräusch
wie immer bei mir ankommen
ich habe gleich ob fisch nee das war so
knapp davor
diese kritik an unendliche quelle hin
ich hatte mir nicht wenn fisch und du
kannst mal wieder runterkommen den
zombie hier wegschlagen ich glaube hier
vor unserer tür stehen unendliche quelle
du kannst oben hangeln das ist deutlich
schöner es geht hier auch ich hab ja ich
hatte grad fast eine art et romantique
gemacht weil ich weiß das ist was ich
komme gleich hoch aber ich probiere noch
einmal mein glück konnten nein
doch jetzt hat geklappt nein wir wollen
auch jetzt du komm hol' eine eigene
angela frau dir deine eigene angel und
alle dort wo du möchtest du bist ich
sitze hier zehn jahre und baue diesem
teich in der wüste erbaut ein teich in
der wüste alles vater morgana und es
dann sagt mir einfach mal mit spieler
nehme ich anderen in seinem kleinen
pfütze komme durch den archiv bekommen
wir das ganze holz hier übrigens das mal
ganz kurz ab alter hier ist ja so viel
holz um mein gott
dafür kommt der fisch kommt erzählt
meine runter ich habe falsch machen du
musst den daten offen alter komme das
holz geht bis nach unten alter jetzt
sind wir deinen produktiv oder sc kommt
so viel holz gleich an unten
ich habe lukas holz gleich wir unten
guck mal versuchen mal diese gar um bei
unbekannt warum warum warum warum warum
warum warum
oh mein gott jetzt auf einmal so richtig
produktiv jetzt auch so viel holz sicher
ich habe angst ja ich habe angst
jetzt richtig viel holz und kommen das
gibt es nach unten hier also wenn das
oben mitgenommen ist dann kommt man mit
ihr nach unten
hast du den tollen teich von mir oben
gesehen ja okay hier hört auf euch
hatten gebratenen fisch es hat geklappt
guck mal hier jetzt mal ohne witz das
meine ich doch auch bei cap tiff
minecraft 1 es geht in sein becken wo du
gesagt hast nie das geht nicht
ich hab's kraft bewiesen es geht ja
stimmen dann geht's wirklich aber ich
habe jetzt extra sandkuhle teilchen
gemacht ob man gut egal wie roman
unendlicher wasserquelle großer computer
dann gebissen oder zu alt für die angst
ganz runter in das dungeon und gucken da
noch mal ja ich muss erstmal meine 24
holz ich geholt habe selber sehr gut
sehr gut so ich pack das holz mal hier
rein mit den ganz anderen sachen die
eimer tue ich aber dann habe ich dann
auch orange gefärbten leben nehmen ganze
nacht ohne nicht achten mal liegen im
ton mal daran soll nämlich hier noch ein
paar süppchen mit darf ich auch noch ton
den sand wollte ich mit im sommer und
dann können wir von mir aus in die höhle
unten gehen wohl die folge auch nicht
mehr so lang geht da liegt noch reisen
drin das pack ich mal eben den ofen soll
ich mal die rüstung anziehen
das kettenhemd oder eher nicht ich mache
uns mal eben wir sagen mal die kiste
ganz links ist eine essens kiste ich tu
dir mal die kekse rhein und den
gebratenen fisch aber am besten man
nicht essen
vielleicht brauchen wir das noch für
irgendwas später oder den gold apfel
auch all den apfel auch nicht essen
ob wir ein fall weil der ist halt so
dass für den markt apple später haben
wir zwei zombies kommt hier nicht rein
hat natürlich stehe euch nicht
reingelassen
der schaden durch die tür richtig macht
die kirche ja durch die war ja die
können doch die tür in kaputt machen war
es nicht so ja da müssen wir aufpassen
eisentüren wie willst du dir dann offen
kriegen dem schalter na ja mit der
druckplatte
man ja auch auf machen egal egal wir
behalten das einfach so gruber hier ist
auch noch mal holz ich hab mal ganz kurz
ich sortiere dass hier gerade mal eben
wir haben schon richtig viel geschafft
ich mir deswegen hab ich mir gedacht
kommen wir hier mal ein bisschen ist ja
meine haupttätigkeit an diesem weg macht
man kann wasserflaschen stecken so ihr
kommt auch noch vergessen so die ganze
und wichtige sachen kommen jeder wieder
raus und mein gott so ihr kommt jetzt
mich alle wieder hier rein
aber ich brauche nämlich keiner hatte
light gray staind night race day können
wir nicht einfach normalen ton rau
aufstellen aber tun die stimmt ohne
nicht enden leon ist ja genau überlegt
hat auch schon ob wir das nicht
irgendwie alles so verbinden können
irgendwie somit weil sie nicht irgendwas
passiert übrigens wer die größte last
jetzt übrigens unsere wertvolle kiste
danach ok weiß ich bescheid
ich kann nur nochmals schilder damit es
aussieht das wird wieder holz kosten
aber hab so viel holz holz muss übrigens
auch in die wertvolle kister total
vergessen heute eigentlich gar nicht
wertvoll aber hier ist es wertvoll so
camcorder auch später zum verzaubern
reisen auch zac meine güte das sind das
sind richtig vorm jan und ich wünsche
wie ein zombie
wer aber auch schon wieder hat ein
knochen gehört da unten liegt erfahrung
ja weil ich da gerade ein kleiner tod
sehr gut okay bekommen wir hier schon
die leiter hoch nähe
noch habe ich glaub die wird uns halt
einfach nur nach oben bringen wir müssen
jetzt mal unten schauen dann unten sind
die gänge weiter aber das werdet ihr bei
gomez sehen weil jetzt die folge vorbei
das war part 6 skeptisch minecraft paar
2 hat teil 2 und 7 kommt morgen bei ghom
auf dem kanal und dann sehen wir uns da
wieder reinschauen